good evening I'm Alexander Rosen the
executive director at the long now
foundation as some of you know we often
screen what we call a long short a short
film that exemplifies long term thinking
this one is exceedingly on topic and is
a detailed documentary narrated by I
believe Jeremy Irons on the life of the
plastic bag the Oh complains of the
asphalt jungle home to many creatures
great and small and the puffing ground
for one of the most clever and
illustrious creatures a plastic bag
today we explore the cycle of life for
this curious creature the plastic bag on
its migration to its home the Pacific
Ocean
once released into the wild the plastic
bag is unsure of itself it falters at
first but soon with some help from the
wind the bag will be airborne this
flight will be the first in its long
journey towards its final destination
the garbage patch in the heart of the
Pacific Ocean using the wind to guide it
the plastic bag moves across the city
through the air a city park this park
may at first seem an idyllic place for
the plastic bag but danger lurks around
every corner here it will encounter many
enemies including one of the most
dangerous Park Service's
poor little fella looks like his journey
ends here meanwhile our little bag has
encountered one of nature's most deadly
killers the teacup Yorkie once the
Yorkie has locked onto its victim his
fellows will hope of survival but using
its superior size and deaf maneuvering
our bag manages to escape the orcas
talons and flee for its life
[Music]
over the course of its miraculous
migration the plastic bag will cover
vast distances through neighborhoods
across parks and on city streets
it is now nightfall and our highly
advanced night-vision cameras have
managed to capture for the first time in
history a plastic bag in pitch black
phenomenal
the vast cement rivers of California
home to literally dozens or animals many
plastic bags will not make it out of
here the reeds and branches will see to
that as at home in water as it is on
land or in the air the bags natural
buoyancy makes it an excellent swimmer
[Music]
it's closed now and it can feel it
at last the bag has reached the gateway
to the open sea
careful to avoid the mouths of hungry
sea life that feed on the helpless
plastic the bag will travel hundreds of
miles to join the thriving community of
plastic known as the Great Pacific
Garbage Patch the garbage patches of
veritable plastic oasis where millions
of tons of plastic garbage remain
trapped by the currents it is said to be
twice the size of Texas
never actually biodegrading here the
plastic bag can live indefinitely
peacefully coexisting with billions of
other petroleum species before breaking
into ever tinier plastic pieces thus
completing the plastic cycle of life
[Music]
my hat is 100% nylon did anybody succeed
in wearing no plastic at all tonight and
not be naked probably yeah
maybe so I came to Susan Franklin's book
the proper way which is learning of the
author's someone to pay attention to you
I've been watching ecological
restoration for a while and doing some
all I can and she wrote a book a couple
years ago called American chestnut the
birth life and death sorry life death
and rebirth of a perfect tree and I knew
that if she wrote anything else I wanted
to read it so just last year she came
out with this book plastic a toxic love
story and I read it with great pleasure
I noticed our previous speaker Charles C
man who's a really diligent guy he read
the speaker before him
ed Wilson's social conquest of Earth and
he read the speaker after in this book
about plastic and he was impressed and
so you scientific journalists are
helping each other along but I realized
that there's a time dimension to plastic
that is at the heart of its
peculiarities and Susan Frankel has
really nailed that and the book and I
think that anything that calls itself
the long now foundation should have a
pretty thorough disquisition and body of
thought around the material like plastic
here she is
Susan Franklin
well thanks Stuart and thank you
everyone for coming so as you see here I
have a slide of the Titanic what you may
ask does the Titanic have to do with
plastic and the answer is that when the
first salvage crew discovered the ship
which went down about a hundred years
ago exactly 100 years ago rather they
found a treasure trove of early 20th
century life they found you know gold
jewelry they found leather goods they
found silver pocket watches there was
one thing they didn't find which was
striking to one of the crew members he
later told reporters there was nothing
on the ship that was plastic not a
single thing and that's kind of
interesting that was only a hundred
years ago and yet you know any modern
ship today that went down it would be a
very different story it would not only
be made of plastic but of course it
would be you know filled with plastic
things in some ways you know the Titanic
is one of the major metaphors of modern
life and plastic too has become a major
metaphor of our time but not just a
metaphor it's also a medium of modern
life it touches pretty much every aspect
of our lives today from clothes to cars
homes to hospitals toys to technology
it's all plastic now I kind of knew this
when I started writing my book on
plastic but I didn't really appreciate
that and I didn't really understand that
as much until I decided to do a little
thought experiment and I thought okay
I'm gonna spend a day not touching
anything plastic it seemed like a great
idea
until the appointed morning when I got
up and sort of stumbled into the
bathroom and looked down and there was
my plastic toilet seat mm-hmm
there was my plastic sink there was my
plastic toothbrush this wasn't going to
work very well so I decided instead that
I was going to spend the day writing
down everything that I touched that was
plastic now this is not this is more
than that list
you know as you can see it's kind of an
impossible amount of stuff and I
realized you know just how thoroughly
plastic our lives were and in some ways
what my book became was an effort to
answer to pretty basic questions one is
how do we get to a place where plastic
is so utterly pervasive in our lives and
then the second is what does that mean
for our lives there are a lot of ways to
tell this kind of story of our kind of
gradual plasticize ation but what really
struck me and to be honest it didn't
really hit me until I was pretty much
done with the book was that one way to
tell the story and think about this
story is as a long love affair that had
gone wrong you know in we started off uh
turley enthralled with plastics even if
we didn't understand very much with them
they became very much a part of our
lives we became somewhat disenchanted
and here we are today pretty
disenchanted still not really
understanding plastics very well but you
get to the point where here we are
utterly dependent on these things that
we often don't like very much and in
some ways that's kind of the you know
perfect definition of a dysfunctional
toxic relationship hence the subtitle of
my book but I believe it's not one that
can't be repaired in fact I think it has
to be fixed because plastics are gonna
be only more important not less
important to us in the future so we hear
a lot about the downsides of plastic
especially in a place like San Francisco
and so I want to spend some time just
reminding us what amazing things
plastics really are and to start with
that I just want to kind of give away a
quick little lesson about being clear
about what plastics are they're polymers
which means they're long chains of
molecules I'm not a tech chemist so I
kind of think about them like daisy
chains daisy chains strung together of
smaller atomic units or molecules this
is a diagram of polyethylene it's the
plastic of packaging you know plastic
bags a lovely plastic bag that we just
saw milk jugs lots and lots of packaging
it this is a pretty simple plastic but
you can get much more complicated ones
and how these strings of the the daisy
chain the pieces of the daisy chain
array
pretty much determines what kind of
plastic you're going to have whether
they're closely packed whether there are
other elements besides hydrogen and
carbon whether there are little side
chains a little dangly you know things
like a charm bracelet those can make a
difference about whether a plastic is
gonna be hard or sticky or clear or
fuzzy or whatever one of the confusions
I think about plastic is we talk about
it the way I've just been talking about
it as if it's a single thing and in fact
there are tens of thousands of different
plastics and they can be as different as
one another as you know glasses from
metal they're also not all the same some
are more useful than others and some are
you know better for the environment
better for our health than others and I
think we forget that sometimes they're
also not all synthetic you know we think
of plastics as these unnatural materials
but plastic polymers are you know very
natural things our DNA is a polymer our
skins are made of copolymer our plants
come made of polymers there are also
natural plastics and they pretty much go
back millennia rubber is a natural
polymer of natural plastic and you know
this is a sort of a picture of I think
it was Mayans playing with the rubber
ball that kind of basketball that they
liked to play amber natural polymer and
this is a vase a jug rather dating from
Roman times horn is a natural polymer
and this is a these are rhino horns from
I think medieval China now the
commercialization of plastics is another
matter that these go back millennia
these natural plastics but the
commercialization really only goes back
to the 19th century and it was something
that was it was a period where the
Victorians were kind of interested in
looking at a new palette of materials
they were tired of just dealing with
wood and metal and glass and they were
also starting to realize that some of
the natural substances that they relied
on were starting to become scarce oh one
of the ones that they were most
concerned about was ivory ivory was used
all over the
it was used for buttons a lots of little
stuff but buttons trays brushes combs
and billiard balls and starting in the
mid 19th century started get these
concerns that so much ivory was being
hunted that elephants were in danger of
going into extinction this is a news
report the the the pullout quote I have
there refers to Sheffield England which
was a center of ivory manufacture so
somewhere around 1869 a billiard ball
manufacturer put out an ad offering
$10,000 to any quote unquote
inventive genius who could come up with
a substitute for ivory and the ad caught
the eye of an amateur inventor in New
York named John Wesley Hyatt this is him
he spent several years tinkering with a
natural polymer cellulose which comes
from the cell walls of plants and
working with camphor and alcohol and
kind of working with recipes that other
people had also been working with as
well and eventually he found a way to
combine them to create this new material
that he called celluloid celluloid was
kind of the start of the romance because
it was a material that offered real
life-changing possibilities it was an
amazing material it was waterproof and
oil proof it was malleable but it could
try to be quite hard you could do all
sorts of cool stuff with celluloid one
of the most amazing things about
celluloid was that you could make it
look like natural substances ivory for
instance a lot of celluloid got made
into dressing sets they called this
French ivory but I don't know why French
ivory but it could also be made to look
like tortoise shelf this is an ear
trumpet it could be made to look like
coral and and you know this capacity to
mimic kind of luxury natural substances
became a major selling point and
ironically you know it was something
that really made this early plastic seen
as a friend of nature this is a quote
from one of the promotional brochures
for hi it's company and as you can see I
mean he's he's plugging this as
something that is going to be
savior of nature not the kind of enemy
of nature that we think of plastics
today it also could be mass manufactured
albeit a much slower pace than later
plastics that would come and one of the
things that that meant was that it
became sort of a medium for the
democratization of consumer goods and of
things that once had been luxury items
in my book I tracked combs and you can
see here examples of these combs that
you know look like what really quite
fantastically expensive items but
actually these weren't expensive they're
made of celluloid and it meant that you
know your average secretary or shop girl
could look like she was a rockefeller
so there were other plastics that came
along celluloid got refined into another
plastic called cellulose acetate which
became the basis for film but the next
really significant plastic was something
that was invented by a Belgian emigres
named leo baekeland like highly baked
'ln was looking for a substitute for a
scarce natural resource in this case
what he was looking to replace with
shellac there was a huge demand for
shellac in the late 19th early 20th
century because it turned out that
shellac was actually a great insulator
for electrical cables and lines and this
was a time when the country was
undergoing rapid electrification and the
trouble is that and I didn't know this
about shellac but shellac is made from
the excretions of the lac beetle and it
takes something like 15,000 beetles six
months to make a pound of shellac you're
not gonna wire up the whole country very
easily that way so you know people were
looking for alternatives and baekeland
again you know working on his own and I
sort of homemade lab came up with this
entirely new material called that he
called after himself bakelite he was not
a modest man bakelite was significant
because it was really the first fully
synthetic molecule unlike celluloid
which came from a natural polymer this
was a completely new molecule never seen
for and though he created it as an
electrical insulator it actually got
used for a lot of stuff and you know
we're familiar with a lot of these
things bakelite telephones the radios
you know all sorts of stuff including of
course billiard balls because as it
turned out celluloid was not very good
for billiard balls it's a flammable
substance and what would happen is when
the billiard balls would collide they'd
make this loud sort of shotgun like
sound and actually there was a saloon
keeper in Denver who wrote Hyatt and
said he didn't mind the noise so much
but every guy in the bar drew a gun when
they heard it so after bakelite we start
to see a change in where plastic comes
from you know Hyatt and baekeland were
lone entrepreneurs working on their own
to solve a very specific problem but you
know by the early 20th century you start
to have these big petroleum country
companies chemical companies
petrochemical companies and you know
companies like DuPont or Dow or Imperial
Chemical in England
you gave Farber and the process of
manufacturing that all of them were
engaged in of making chemicals or
refining oil are processes that generate
huge amounts of waste huge amounts of
waste products and byproducts and you
know being good capitalist enterprises
they're trying to figure out what to do
with this stuff and they've got by this
time now industrial chemistry
departments and they set the research
scientists to work trying to figure out
what to do with this stuff and what
happens in the teens 20s and 30s is this
great burst of creativity fantastic new
polymer inventions EJ Farber said was
inventing a new polymer every day in the
mid 1920s and in fact most of the major
plastics we know today things like
polyethylene poly vinyl chloride
polystyrene acrylic nylon all of them
come out of this what's considered like
the golden era of polymer innovation a
lot easing materials actually were
accidental discoveries you know
polyethylene for instance was literally
the product of a lab accident there was
an explosion in this reactor vessel the
the scientists looked in at the next
morning and there's this kind
white waxy stuff at the bottom of the
vessel they had no idea what it was or
what to do with it they actually thought
it was a useless material same story for
teflon but obviously people did start to
figure out what to do with these things
nylon for instance was not an accidental
invention and DuPont knew exactly what
to do with it there's huge excitement I
don't know where this is from I just
think it's a hilarious photo but nyeh
DuPont spent years developing nylon and
when they finally had it they kind of
unveiled it in these very masterful
campaigns they showed it off at places
like the Golden Gate Exposition of 1939
we have these models hustling over a
pair of stockings to show how strong it
was
they began carefully doling out nylons
to department stores and limiting the
amounts that people could buy so you
actually literally had nylon right Riots
this picture is from I think it's from
Cincinnati I'm not sure where main 15
1940 the first week nylons went on sale
in the US and you know incredible
excitement on the part of women so the
love affair is starting to heat up there
was this great sense of excitement about
these new materials even if people
weren't seeing a lot of them because in
point of fact plastics was still a very
small industry and there weren't a lot
of products out there but there were
these trade shows and there were like
the you know DuPont had their wonderful
world of chemistry show that they used
to take around bakelite had a traveling
Calva Cade and I in my book I quote this
woman at one DuPont exhibit who gushed
you know isn't it wonderful how DuPont
is improving upon nature people told
pollsters around this time that
cellophane was the third most beautiful
word in the English language
after motherhood and memory this is just
one of a trio of ads there's one with
twins wrapped in cellophane and there's
actually one with triplets wrapped in
cellophane so there's a lot of
excitement about the promise of plastic
even though people didn't have a lot of
it in their daily
life and not a lot was being made out of
plastic what changed things World War
two started the war the military was
clear that they wanted to conserve
strategic metals and materials and they
called on the plastics industry which
then was really a nascent industry to
see if they could come up with
replacements for things like brass or
steel or silk or rubber and the industry
complied this is one of the first things
that got made out of plastic it's a
plastic bugle that was made by a company
that had only just started making them
they had manufactured like a red toy
bugle the previous Christmas and the
company managed to put together a
prototype when they were asked by the
army like in the space of two weeks and
it's a funny story the president of the
company had only one prototype he took
it down to Washington where their major
who was in charge of this stuff had the
Army's best bugler on hand to see if he
could play it and he played taps and he
played revelry and then he played them
nearby and then he had the guy go off
I'm half mile away to see if they could
still hear it then they threw it against
a brick wall to see how terrible it was
and when it passed muster they made two
hundred thousand the major then went on
to order whistles and helmets and other
sorts of plastic substitutes plastic
went into parachutes went into the
acrylic windows for for bombers who went
into gas masks this mortar fuse and I
really actually don't know what a mortar
fuse is but it was the first
million-dollar order of plastics so
we're in the war years and as so often
happens during wartime the romance
deepens people hear about these amazing
new materials and they're being told
these heroic feats that plastics are
performing in battle and they come to be
seen as critical to to the Allies
success and in fact they were
polyethylene that plastic that no one
could figure out what to do with well it
turns out polyethylene is really good at
shielding radio frequencies and
shielding radio transmission lines and
so they were able to use polyethylene to
build radar that was light enough to put
on planes and airborne radar really
proved critical to the Allies winning
the war because the Germans actually
didn't have polyethylene Teflon again
another you know who knows what to do
with this polymer
that was used in the Manhattan Project
because it could withstand very
corrosive gases and these two line
vessels for the some of the gases that
were being used to develop the atomic
bomb Saran was a plastic that was used
to to coat boats and ships and and
planes to protect them against saltwater
and wind
heroic qualities that got turned to
sandwich rap after the war and became a
selling point
so historian Jeffrey Michael has a very
good book about the history of plastic
talks about the kind of not just love
but the sort of utopian vision that
people had about plastic in the 40s and
nowhere was it clearer than this
statement from two-bit british chemists
who are writing just before the war but
in many ways the sentiments they wrote
were just as strong if not stronger
after the war so let you take a look at
this you know let us try to imagine a
dweller in the plastic age this plastic
man will come into a world of color and
bright shining surfaces where childish
hands find nothing to break no sharp
edges or corners to cutter graze no
crevices to harbored dirt or germs it is
world free from moth and rust and full
of color a world in which man like a
magician makes what he wants for almost
every need and I love this quote because
he no it actually describes the world we
live in today in many ways but we've
seen the dystopian side of this vision
so you know the first time I read this I
just kind of cringed it's hard to
reconnect with the sort of wonder that's
behind these words now come the end of
the war you have this big built up
production capacity and you have a
pent-up consumer demand it's not hard to
see what's going to happen next which
was an explosion in plastics production
this just goes back to 1950 but as you
can see you know it just sort of shoots
upward and upward and upward and what's
not marked on this but it's worth noting
is in 1979 plastics production exceeded
that of Steel and so some people take
that as sort of the official start of
the age of plastic I think it goes much
further back but you know as one
plastics executive recalled in 1946
virtually nothing was made of plastic
and almost anything
could be and so almost anything was in
1946 the industry held its first first
national plastics exposition and they
invited the public to come it was a
trade show but eighty-seven thousand
people lined up four abreast four blocks
in New York to get into this show eager
for a chance to see stuff that to us
would be very prosaic now I mean things
like nylon fishing line or you know
crystal clear acrylic or suitcases that
you know could carry a heavy load but
we're very lightweight themselves or
window screens that you know came in
their own colors plastics to them seemed
to promise abundance on the cheap and so
you know who wouldn't be in favor of
that it was particularly exciting to a
generation that had come through the
privations of the Depression had come
through the scrimping and saving and
scrounging of the of the war and who now
had you know a lot of money to spend
plastics you know they could also see
was gonna help democratize consumer
goods in the same way that celluloid had
but on a much broader scale and would
make it possible for middle-class people
to enjoy a whole new level of material
wealth so what happens over the next
decade fifteen years or so is that you
get this flood of plastic stuff going
into household appliances electronics
home furnishings I like this photo
it's captioned mother's nightmare it was
in Life magazine in 1946 and it was
designed to demonstrate the toughness of
plastics and I don't know if you can see
it clearly but the kid on the couch is
writing on the wall the little girl has
just spilled pudding on the chair and
the boy in the corner is trying to light
the curtains on fire
and and the caption was if this were the
usual kind of room that children would
be doing a hundred and fifty dollars
worth of damage but you know is plastic
so it's all safe and in fact you know
throughout the 50s if you look in the
women's magazines there are all these
basically advertorial articles going on
about you know how much convenience
plastics would bring and they all kind
of have this one line over and over
again you know you can wipe clean with a
damp cloth Plastics you know we're used
in automotive the the acrylic taillight
you wouldn't think of it but it was
actually a big deal a big innovation and
got showed off of course permitted the
Corvette which was made almost entirely
of fiberglass plastics you know made
possible these whole new fabrics this is
from a 1953 Sears catalog you know
touting fabrics that not many people
would brag about today but things like
orlon or Dacron new textiles for
wash-and-wear clothing again you know
for people for women especially who had
been ironing stuff you could imagine how
wonderful this sounded because of the
baby-boom plastics became common in toys
now this busy bee I don't know how many
of you remember this but I do the
fisher-price busy bee was actually the
first toy to use plastic styrene for the
little wings but it also made possible
Barbie and the frisbee this is the
frisbees inventor Walt Morrison who
actually his original invention was a
disc he called the Pluto platter and of
course then he had to dress up like this
to advertise it until he sold it to
whammo
you had the hula hoop the hula hoop was
made from high-density polyethylene and
actually the story behind the hula hoop
was that Phillips Petroleum was trying
to get down the recipe for this
particular kind of plastic and they
couldn't get it right they kept
producing piles of off spec material
they had sort of warehouses of it and
whammo which was then a pretty new
company heard about it and said you know
we'll take that off your hands and they
made this toy which was really kind of
the first big toy craze you know sort of
the tickle-me-elmo of its time legos of
course a made of plastic and then you
get silly putty so silly putty with
actually something that was invented
because the the inventor of Scylla silly
putty
had been commissioned by the army to
come up with a replacement a synthetic
rubber and this is what he came up with
the army said I don't think so but you
know silly putty you know it's just
something that begs to be touched and
played with so he got in the habit of
carrying it around in his pocket and he
would you know have it with him he'd go
to parties pull it out show people the
cool stuff you can do how you can pull
newsprint off and he was at a party
where there was a woman who owned a toy
company and she said I know what we can
do with that the thing is at a certain
point it becomes clear that there really
only so many cars and refrigerators and
stereos and toys and clothes that you
can make the plastics industry wanted to
keep growing and you know that was
looking for new markets and at a certain
point it became clear what was the next
market for plastics disposables and it
really was a conscious strategy you look
at the trade journals and you see people
in the industry talking about how to
develop the disposables market there was
you know a conference where one
executive said to people there
your future is in the garbage wagon and
so now you start to get a whole new kind
of use of plastic that going into
packaging that stop that deodorant on
your left that was actually the first
squeeze bottle ever I think it was
introduced in 1953 you get things like
these soap bottles you get disposable
diapers which you know pundits used to
say was the reason for the baby boom you
get you know ideas like disposable
clothes you get you know the sort of
ephemera were so used to today razors
and lighters which actually were you
know launched by BIC and there were big
wars between BIC and Gillette over who
was going to control those markets
cling-wrap
this sort of thing you get vending
machines with disposable cups and
actually when the first coffee vending
machines came out people tended to save
and reuse the cups much to the
consternation of the plastics industry
and again you look in trade journals and
you see you know people talking about
how can we teach people and encourage
people to throw those cups away
we did learn so if coffee is good in a
vending machine why not or better still
communion cups throw away communion cups
it's a silly example but you can see how
the idea of disposability builds and so
eventually you know we come to the
celebration that what what Life magazine
called the throwaway lifestyle and this
photo was a celebration of what
disposable is enabled making life easier
more convenient cleaner the stuff being
tossed here life you know said in the
kind of exultant caption would have
taken the housewife the very happy mom
in the middle of the picture more than a
hundred hours to clean now plastics
didn't create the disposable lifestyle
of a throwaway mindset there were a lot
of cultural and economic forces behind
that the rise of suburbia the
development of self-serve grocery stores
the development of fast food chains
self-serve pharmacies all these things
you know called for more packaging the
building of the interstate highway
system actually played a major role in
the end of refillable bottles for
beverages because the bottlers didn't
have to have to stick to regional
networks any longer but you know
disposable bottles surely got a boost
when in 1971 the brother of the artist
Andrew Wyeth a chemical engineer named
Nathaniel Wyeth found a way to make the
plastic soda bottle found a way to take
PE T plastic and allow it to hold this
very kind of explosive carbonated
beverage and look what happens when you
have a plastic bottle you know that was
the large size in the 1930s on the left
and you know that's nothing compared to
the large size today so plastic didn't
create this kind of culture of
convenience or throwaway mindset but
it's facilitated it they facilitated it
because plastics were cheap lightweight
and we got better and better at making
polymers that could do exactly what we
wanted them to do you know I talked to a
guy in the course of my reporting one of
the guys I talked to was a scientist who
was involved in developing the bagged
lettuce the bag for lettuce which
actually
I didn't know it turns out it's really
the product of a pretty strenuous
scientific investigation to find a
polymer that can allow exactly the right
respiration rate to allow the oxygen in
and the carbon dioxide out so that
lettuce won't wilt err you know mold too
quickly as the culture of convenience
took hold plastic really was
increasingly the material used for
packaging and throwaways those same
virtues of plastic cheapness lightweight
nearly infinite malleability also meant
it was used increasingly for whole new
varieties of schlock the you know icon
of schlock the plastic pink flamingos
and I actually talked to the guy who
invented it Don Featherstone who told me
he was very proud to have brought bad
taste to the masses you know the irony
here is that as plastic assumed a
greater and greater place in our lives
we became more and more disenchanted
with it the linguist Geoffrey nunberg
dates the sort of scales falling away
moment to the core fam debacle I don't
know how many of you are old enough to
remember core fam but it was this fake
leather that DuPont spent years trying
to develop and tens of million dollars
to develop it was going to be the you
know the future shoe the shoe of the
future but the problem was that core fam
shoes when they were introduced in the
early 60s were awful they didn't breathe
they didn't stretch they were
uncomfortable and after about I don't
know seven years or so
DuPont sold the line to a company in
Poland and for the first time what
happens in the 60s is you start seeing
plastic getting used as a word not you
know the most wonderful word in the
human language but as a word to mean
shallow or phony or insincere you know
hence this punchline
now of course mr. McGuire was right in
1960 the average American consumed about
30 pounds of plastic a year today we
consume more than 300 pounds of plastic
a year and of course some of that's
going into incredibly important and
valuable things MRI machines computers
cell phones clothing microwaves
lightweight cars and planes
but a lot of it is accounted for by
disposables in fact about half of all
plastic produced goes into single-use
applications and about a third of that
goes into packaging and again no
question a lot of that is really
important
disposable syringes are vital to
preventing the spread of infectious
diseases packaging in a world global
food economy is also a essential even in
a national food economy but with plastic
it's just always all too easy to go too
far so this single serving banana
wrapped in plastic which Jon Stewart
said is for people who love bananas but
hate the bud biodegradability of the
skin when plastic at you gets used for
this kind of ridiculous science stuff
it's really easy to lose sight of the
fact that these are really high value
materials so here we are today the
romance is soured in many ways but the
dependence keeps growing which as I
mentioned before is kind of the classic
definition of a dysfunctional
relationship now some folks want an
all-out divorce you can see things like
this but I don't think that's realistic
or even desirable you know plastics are
going to be important for our future
especially in an era of global warming
where carbon becomes the metric the
important metric you know not many
materials can compete with plastic given
their lightweightness we want
lightweight plastic cars and trains and
planes we want plastic you know housing
components and solar panels in a world
of seven billion people and growing
we're not going to be able to feed and
clothe and heal and house all those
people purely from the materials of the
natural world we're gonna need
synthetics but I do think there are some
serious issues related to plastics that
we're gonna have to start dealing with
so let's start with this one is the fact
that these are materials that are made
out of fossil fuels now it takes about
4% of the supplies of oil and maybe
about 7 or 8% of natural gas to go into
making plastics that's you know not an
insignificant number it's not
than compared to say cars but it would
be better to find renewable sources for
these things and I'll come back later I
think the second issue is the problem of
plastic waste we generate close to 32
million tons of plastic waste a year and
that figure is a little misleading if
you think about the fact that plastic is
very lightweight if it would be a much
different figure if I had it in volume
but it's about 12% of the waste stream
the vast majority of that stuff goes to
landfill which again is insane if you
think about it these are hydrocarbons
valuable hydrocarbons that we extracted
from the ground at great expense at
great environmental cost and we're
burying them that's nuts
but as the Green Line shows almost none
of this stuff is recycled less than 10%
which is way less than any other
material you know those chasing arrows
that are always on the bottom of plastic
packages those are incredibly misleading
because although most plastic things are
eminently recyclable very little is
actually recycled there are a lot of
reasons for that
plastics are a challenge for recyclers
many of them look alike but they can't
be recycled together if you mix say a PE
tea soda bottle which is the number one
plastic with you know a PVC bottle
number three you're going to just get
this unusable gloop in some cases it's
really difficult to actually collect
them it's it's not economical that's
been the challenge with things like
plastic bags and styrofoam both of which
are so lightweight that it's just not
economical to truck around a truckload
of them in other cases there aren't
enough end markets to make it worthwhile
and this is sort of a you know
self-fulfilling prophecy but that's been
the problem with polypropylene number
five plastic which is the stuff you see
in yogurt tubs margarine tubs
polypropylene is in great plastic it's
probably one of the best plastic sout
there it's clean it's safe but but there
haven't been end markets for it and so
it hasn't been recycled in any great
amounts that's starting to change Whole
Foods has this gimme five program where
you can take back yogurt tubs and a lot
of it goes to this company called
preserve which makes them into things
like toothbrushes and
and bowls and you know the recycling
situation is improving but not fast
enough
and I was actually surprised to find
that the recycling infrastructure is so
sort of weak and flawed that a lot of
the plastics collected in communities
end up being shipped to China even in
San Francisco so I visited a recycling
plant in China this is one that doesn't
recycle consumer waste but industrial
waste from the US and as you can see
here you know these are literally these
women are standing there with these
enormous bags of plastic sheeting stuff
that doesn't get recycled in this
country and they're you know by hand
cutting the labels off so that it can be
reprocessed meanwhile American recyclers
and of the the PE tea soda bottles I
should say the number one soda bottles
which are the most recycled material in
this country most of those go to China
where they are recycled into fleece and
into polyester fill into fabric
meanwhile recyclers in this country
can't get enough used bottles and are
importing them from Mexico and other
parts of Latin America something is very
wrong here when this is going on I think
probably the most serious fallout though
from our failure to deal with plastic
waste is the problem of plastic litter
plastic doesn't break down like paper or
even metal it will eventually biodegrade
and you know contrary to popular ideas
plastic is not forever but you know is
that ten years a hundred years a
thousand years you know it depends it
depends on the plastic depends on the
environment and in any case it's not a
meaningful timeframe any plastic in the
environment is going to be there a very
very long time and that becomes a real
problem when it ends up in the ocean
which is where we know a lot of plastic
ends up plastics been found on beaches
and seas around the world and incredibly
remote places I talked to one researcher
who described going to a tiny like
little rocky outcropping aptly named
inaccessible island near Antarctica his
crew went ashore in one of their zodiacs
and there they found plastic bottles
you've all heard reports about the North
Pacific Garbage Patch and contrary to
that film which we just saw it really
doesn't look anything like the the
plastic there does not look like what
they showed in the film you actually
don't find a lot of plastic bags there
because they get broken up by the time
they get that far out but it's an area
in the Pacific where currents and
atmospheric conditions create a slow
vortex that kind of traps that pulls in
and traps trash from North America and
Asia a lot of it's from Asia and
actually this is a little misleading
because really what it looks like is
sort of a dog bone shape with two two
convergent zones one near Asia one near
the US North America what doesn't
eventually stuff gets trapped there for
a while and then eventually gets spit
back out and you ends up often on
beaches and you know unfortunately this
is not the only such place there at
least five similar gyres around the
world
how much is in them nobody can really
tell you probably the North Pacific has
the most because it's also such a
heavily traveled trade route but you
know how much is there it I wouldn't
trust any number because there's really
no way to know the plastic isn't just on
the surface it's suffuse through the
water column I do know that there was a
study that came out about two weeks ago
that found that the concentration of
plastic there had probably increased
about a hundredfold since the early 70s
which makes sense I mean our production
and consumption has gone up
significantly since then this is a
picture of a Laysan albatross many of
you probably seen pictures similar to
this or this one the Laysan albatross is
a bird that nests on Midway at all and
the adult birds forage for food out in
the ocean and area that includes the
Garbage Patch and that means that often
they're picking up stuff that they
mistake for their traditional food like
squid eggs and they bring it back to
their nests on the atoll and they feed
it to their young biologists on Midway
now estimate that pretty much every one
of the 1.1 million Birds there has some
quantity of plastic in their guts
it's
sounds awful in point of fact we don't
actually know what the health
consequences are to the birds these
birds are evolved to deal with
indigestible stuff but there is some
suspicion that you know the plastic in
their guts means that they can't
actually tell when they're hungry or
thirsty and a significant number of
birds there do die of dehydration
unfortunately the albatross is not alone
you know all told there's something like
267 species that have been impacted
injured impaired entangled or killed by
plastic and that's you know
three-fourths of all sea turtles this
includes the leatherback turtle which is
an animal that has been around since the
time of the dinosaurs it also includes
under the marine mammals monk seals
which are these a very endangered
population in the Hawaiian Islands
Plastics not the only thing that's
killing them but the entanglement by
ghost nets is certainly hurrying them
toward extinction now most plastic in
the ocean doesn't stay in the form that
you see it in this bird or as the the
movie on the plastic bag showed most of
it actually gets broken down into little
bits little tiny pieces and that poses a
whole other set of issues it's it's
these little bits seem to be affecting
the ocean ecology there was just a
report showing that a particular variety
of sea insect is depositing eggs on
these little bits and much higher
numbers than ever before who knows what
that's going to do to the ecosystem out
there but the other and sort of more
worrisome immediately worrisome thing is
that these tiny bits absorb toxins that
are already in the ocean they're like
sponges and they pick up things like
PCBs and DDT s persistent organic
pollutants that have been in the oceans
that were banned you know three decades
for decades ago but persist in the ocean
and and get absorbed onto these little
plastic bits now for this problem this
might be the poster child this is a
lantern fish it's much less charismatic
than the albatross but it's mothers love
them they're deep sea dwellers that come
up at night to feed on plankton on the
surface and research suggests
that as long with the plankton they're
also eating these little plastic bits
the recent studies found 9 percent of
those sampled had plastic and there's in
their guts the concern is if the toxins
on these plastics can sorb off of the
bits into the fish tissue you have a
vehicle for moving these toxins up the
food chain as they are eaten by bigger
and bigger and bigger fish and
eventually by us the problem of plastic
pollution in the ocean is a really tough
one it's not going to be easily cleared
up I mean there are people who are doing
programs like hauling in abandoned Nets
and recycling them into oil but you
can't do that with this confetti that
suffuses the water really the only
answer for that is going to be stopping
it at the source which means going back
to this problem of plastic waste
resolving it finding ways to reduce our
use of it recycle more and get better
collection infrastructures there's
another big problem with plastic and
that is the fact that there most
plastics are made are often made with
hazardous materials bio money bio
monitoring studies are showing that the
chemicals contained in plastics can
often wind up in us nearly all of us
even those who live the most crunchy
super organic groovy lives are carrying
traces of things like plasticizers and
flame retardants and Teflon and
bisphenol A in our systems there really
is no escaping this so what are the
risks well it's hard to know because you
can't do controlled experiments with
people instead we are kind of the
experiment an uncontrolled experiment
but animal studies and epidemiological
studies are coming back with some
worrisome information this is you know
BPA bisphenol A pretty well known it's
used to make polycarbonate plastics the
hard clear plastic that you would see
the number 7 on packaging bisphenol A
was literally invented as a synthetic
estrogen and it seems to mimic estrogen
in the body and it's been associated
with as I said it's it's used to make
polycarbonate plastic
it's used in the epoxies that line food
and beverage cans and you'll find it in
bottles less than you used to can
linings it comes on the thermal cash
receipts and you know animal and cell
studies come up with some pretty
worrisome findings human studies show
correlations with some serious illnesses
it's a estrogen mimic and it seems to
act on systems that are responsible
responsive to estrogen
phalates is another phthalates are used
as solvents lubricants plasticizers
they're found in soft vinyl PVC in its
native form is sort of this brittle
plastic and the only way that you can
make it usable is with additives to make
it soft and flexible they use phthalates
and so you find them in a whole slew of
things this list is a very incomplete
list and again you know it's a hormone
disruptor in this case it seems to
interfere with testosterone and so it
affects systems that testosterone touch
and you'll see that last one there play
behavior that's from a study by a woman
named Shanna Swan who's been following
one particular phthalates called de HP
for some time she has a group of
children that she's been following since
before birth she measured the levels of
de HP and their mothers and then has
been looking at what happened to the
boys the sons of these mothers from
birth on and she's found some pretty
unsettling things one of the weirdest
and kind of in some ways really
disturbing is that when she went back to
these kids as preschoolers she found
that the boys whose mothers had the
highest levels of de HP and I want to
add here this is not big levels these
are environmental regular exposures
everyday exposures the mothers who
scored highest in that their sons tended
to play engage in sort of less masculine
forms of play they were the boys who
liked to sit and play with puzzles or
with board games the boys that many
mothers would like to have best but you
know there was a distinctive difference
and it turns out that play behavior is a
kind of hardwired behavior that is
affected by androgens in the system
other chemicals there are other
chemicals that are found in plastics
that that are concerned brominated flame
there's the antibacterial trick listen
nominal phenols styrene in fact you know
that's I I talked with one expert who's
estimated that there's some 50 of these
so-called endocrine disruptors that have
been approved for use in food contact
materials much of which are plastic the
fact is though we really don't know
which ones are exposed to or how much
we're exposed to because manufacturers
aren't required to list the chemical
contents of their packages or other
materials on the label and given the
long supply chain of plastics often they
may not even know themselves what
they're selling so here's where we come
to a really tough problem which is this
is not something we can really deal with
as consumers the laws in this country
tend to treat chemicals as if they were
safe until proven harmful and that's
just created an incredibly you know that
is reflected in an incredibly weak
regulatory system most of the 80,000
plus chemicals that are in commerce
today have never really been
sufficiently vetted for safety the EPA
has you know managed to doesn't test
most chemicals that are in process same
thing for the FDA which approved a slew
of chemicals for food contact uses back
in the 1960s and has never really gone
back and reviewed them now alternatives
are being developed and even put into
use for example there are sort of citrus
based chemicals and and castor oil based
chemicals that are being used as
replacements for phthalates as a
plasticizer for vinyl but really you
know the market forces that are
encouraging the development of these
things aren't really an answer for the
underlying problem of our weak
regulatory system because you know take
a look at BPA you'd be hard-pressed
today to find a baby bottle or sports
water bottle that has BPA and it instead
you see this kind of label so what does
that mean what's in it there's nothing
on the bottle that tells you what this
plastic is there are a couple of
different plastics are being used as
replacements at least one of which is
pretty closely related to BPA are they
safe who knows we don't know and we
won't know as long
as we continue to regulate on a chemical
by chemical basis and work off of the
assumption that chemicals are safe until
proven otherwise you know what we really
need is a shift in regulation that
requires as Europe does that
manufacturers demonstrate a chemical is
safe before they're allowed to put it on
the market
that's not the system we have now so
these issues about plastics aren't new
there's been evidence about plastic in
the ocean since the 60s there's been
evidence about plastic leeching chemical
since before that but I think we've
reached a crossroads we've made nearly
as much plastic in the last in the first
decade of this millennium as we did in
the entire preceding century and though
production dipped slightly when the
market collapsed in 2008 it started to
pick up again and now we have a whole
new wrinkle encouraging more production
which is shale gas most plastic in this
country is made from natural gas and the
shale gas boom is just like you know
Christmas every day - the plastics
industry already you've got 9 companies
have announced that they're going to be
building crackers which are the big
furnaces that break up hydrocarbons into
the gases that are used to make
chemicals and plastics 9 companies have
announced plans for new crackers
including one in Pennsylvania what that
means what this sort of obscure slide
translates to is that there's going to
probably be about 25% more polyethylene
coming into the market over the next
several years that's gonna have to go
somewhere and I think what you're gonna
see is a big push for new outlets of
polyethylene new kinds of packaging new
kinds of products there was a similar
push starting in the 60s when the
polyethylene industry took off and
that's why instead of paper bags we have
plastic dry cleaner bags plastic produce
bags plastic garbage bags and of course
the most ubiquitous plastic bag of all
the plastic shopping bag the other place
that all this new polyethylene is
probably going to go is overseas because
in many parts of the world Asia Africa
Latin America people want to have the
same kind of lifestyle that we have
dates they want to enjoy the sort of
convenience and middle-class comforts
that we've enjoyed in the US and in
Europe and these are the big new markets
for plastics this is where a lot of the
new demand is coming from and these are
countries with even less developed
infrastructures for waste in many cases
so many people are looking at you know
solving the problems through a whole new
class of plastics bio plastics plastics
made from renewable sources there's a
big push now on the part of all the
major resin manufacturers the plastics
makers to start looking for renewable
sources get away from fossil fuels and
right now these bio plastics represent
about 1% of the whole resin market but
it's definitely the long-term future you
don't see these kind of demand numbers
in this chart for a regular Petro
plastics anymore and you know it's a
funny future because it's a kind of Back
to the Future future if you think about
it I mean we started with plant
place-based
plastics with celluloid so people are
looking at a lot of different sources I
apologize for the fuzziness of this
chart but it just gives you a sense of
you know you could make bio-based
plastics from a lot of different
feedstocks from agricultural crops from
non agricultural crops you can make it
from bacteria that generate polymers you
can make it from switchgrass and and bio
grass biomass you can make it from
agricultural waste you can make it from
our waste there are people looking at
making plastics out of sewage and out of
the methane that comes off of landfills
unfortunately I think there's a lot of
confusion about bio plastics as you know
this list of feedstocks suggests bio
plastics like petro plastics are not a
single thing there's a lot of different
bio-based plastics and what they can do
what problems they can solve what
problems they create really varies it
depends on a material and it depends on
how it's going to be used there's one
problem you could say all of these
bio-based plastic solves and that's the
carbon footprint of plastic whether
you're using corn whether you're using
you know corn stover whether you're
using switchgrass these are all going to
have low
our carbon footprint than fossil fuel
based plastics even when you factor in
the water and the fertilizer and all
that that's used but bio plastics don't
solve necessarily the end-of-life issues
being bio-based doesn't make a plastic
biodegradable those are different things
you can actually have in plastics made
from fossil fuels that biodegrade and
you can have plastics made from bio
sources that don't biodegrade one of the
most common plastics bio plastics out
there right now is called poly lactic
acid PLA Korn plastic or it's marketed
under the name NGO it's made by nature
works which is owned by Cargill so not
surprisingly it's made by from corn and
it's being using in a lot of stuff this
was the plastic made famous when Sun
Chips came out with their compostable
bag that was so loud when it crinkled
the people said it had the same sort of
loudness of a jet cockpit they had to
reformulate it these are the things that
we reject plastic products on the
loudness of crinkling
problem with this plastic among other
things is that technically it's
compostable but you're not going to make
it break down in your backyard composter
there are even commercial composting
facilities that say that things made
from PLA don't break down within the
camera burst at 60 days 120 days that
they're supposed to and and most
communities in the US don't have
composing infrastructures so in theory
it's a great plastic but in practice you
know it doesn't have an end-of-life
solution built into it really and
meanwhile recyclers hate it because if
it gets mixed up with a bale of
conventional plastics it's just going to
muck them up another kind of bioplastic
out there is the plant bottle the plant
bottle is right now it's it's made from
sugarcane about 1/3 of the bottle now is
actually this plant based plastic this
is not a new plastic what what coke and
the the brass cam the Brazilian partner
that's making this stuff did is they're
using sugar cane to make the exact same
molecule as regular number one PE T
plastic
this is not a biodegradable plastic it
has to be recycled arguably that was a
good thing but you know it's better to
go into a recycling stream that exists
then the sort of scarcely existed
composting squeeze stream so these
materials only address the waste problem
if the manufacturers have worked that
into the design of the base resin and
the products made from it bio plastics
also aren't an automatic answer to the
issue of hazardous chemicals in plastic
they're only safer if they're made with
safer materials and that means this
commitment to safety throughout the
supply chain and that can be difficult
to ensure in 2010 Stonyfield farms
decided they wanted to package a new
type of children's yogurt in corn
plastic and they went to their
compounder these are the guys who take
sort of a base plastic and mix in
various additives to give it you know
just the right properties that that
somebody wants and they said you know we
have figured out everything that's in
this but the last three percent can you
tell us what's in that three percent
because we really want to make sure
there's nothing nasty in here that
children would eat and the compounder
said no that's a proprietary trade
secret
so what Stonyfield actually ended up
having to do was come up with a list of
2300 different chemicals that it wanted
to make sure we're not in this little
yogurt cup and present it to the
compounder and have the compounders say
yeah that none of those are in there for
them to really sort of feel secure now
this is Stonyfield farms backed by you
know group then on which is one of the
biggest food companies in the world and
you know they to their credit they were
willing to take that extra step this is
just a quick start chart to show you
that you know again bio plastics measure
up differently they measure this was a
study looking at this sustainability of
bio plastics and as you can see here
quickly you know when you measure for
occupational health and safety you can
come up with a different ranking than
when you measure for environmental
impacts and in the end the study
concluded that really no bioplastic out
there is fully sustainable yet put it
another way
their efforts afoot to develop a soy
based polyvinyl chloride now
all the plastics out there polyvinyl
chloride PVC is a really problem plastic
it's made with chlorine and because of
that it's a nightmare to manufacture
it's hazardous to manufacture and it's a
nightmare to dispose of because of its
burn it releases dioxins and furans into
the atmosphere you know incredibly
potent carcinogens and you know it's a
brittle plastic and so it almost always
needs additives including things like
phalates
you know as the carbon issue significant
enough to make this issue this kind of
plastic from plants or should we just
get rid of it another example
biodegradable bags I mean do we really
need single use bags you know there may
be a place for them there may be a place
for biodegradable bags but maybe we
should rethink the whole bag issue
sometimes I look at biopolymers and I
think you know we're kind of at the same
place the plastic industry was at
following World War two huge enthusiasm
huge excitement and a desire to put
these new plastics anyplace possible and
a desire for sort of a silver bullet
solution to our plastic woes you know a
sense that here is a partner that at
last will solve all of our kind of
dysfunctional plastic relationships but
there are lots of outstanding challenges
and questions as we move on to this next
generation of plastics how much do we
use food crops should we use food crops
or even more controversially
genetically modified food crops for bio
plastics or genetically modified
bacteria which is a whole kind of a
whole sort of line of bio plastics can
we use sustainably grown biomass for
plastics to what extent can we exploit
the waste that's already present you
know which after all the use of waste
was really what gave plastics of leg-up
economically speaking back in the late
19th century or early 20th century you
know what will it take to develop a
composting or recycling infrastructure
to deal with these plastics at the end
of their lives because they're not good
in landfills if the bot if the plastic
biodegrades in a landfill if you have a
biodegradable plastic in a landfill it's
going to generate methane which is an
even more potent greenhouse gas than co2
you know what I'm suggesting here is
that the promise of bioplastics depends
on really rethinking our relationship to
plastics how we make them how we produce
them how we use them and you know by
extension kind of rethinking our whole
material world this time around I'm
really hoping that we can give it a more
holistic cradle-to-cradle approach where
we ensure that the plastics we make the
products we make from them you know can
either be recycled back into nature or
into technology this is a bridge it's a
this is story that I end my book with
and this is another way of sort of
thinking forward about plastics this
bridge was built by a New Jersey company
that has commercialized a technology
that takes old milk jugs and car bumpers
and she pushes them together I don't
know how but smushes them together to
make this incredibly durable strong
tough material they're making i-beams
out of it then using them to build docks
and marinas and in this case bridges
this bridge was built in Fort Bragg and
as you can see it's strong enough to
hold an m1 Abrams tank other bridges
they've built from the same material are
being used for railroad bridges so it's
a really strong material and I like it
because you know bridge metaphor for
moving to the future and I think you
know millennia from now when
archaeologists scraped down through the
stratum of this era which my friend the
beach plastic artist Richard Liang has
called the plasticine you know are they
going to find it simply stuffed with
immortal throwaways or you know can we
change the way we make and use plastics
so what they find are artifacts like
this bridge which I think really
testified to our technical ingenuity and
to our wisdom to use that technology
well so thank you all
let's go over here and sit down and deal
with some questions yes good so the long
now audience is interested in this
who else is interested who's asking to
you to give these talks oh it was well
you know it's interesting I thought that
my audience would be environmentalist
but I'm actually hearing from industry
who I don't know if it's just sort of
you know kind of a confessional thing or
if they're really interested in hearing
this but they at least some people in
industry are interested in hearing this
message say more about that you said
where have you gone what happens there
well not a whole lot but um you know one
of the one of the more interesting talks
that I gave there's a group of plastic
bag manufacturers in California who are
a really interesting group because
unlike the plastic industry as a whole
these folks really saw the writing on
the wall about marine debris and they
really recognized that this is a serious
issue they had to grapple with but they
make plastic bags and you know they're
not really interested in giving up that
business and they've been trying to sort
of figure out some way of either you
know encouraging recycling of bags
making thicker bags whatever and they
invited me to come speak and I was
really nervous cuz I thought you know I
invited me I said are you guys just
gonna yell at me and she said no no they
really want to hear what you have to say
and they actually were great they
actually were very interested and they
wanted me to come back you know to talk
to their fellow members in Canada so I
think they you know they want to hear
they don't want to have people just
yelling at them they want to sort of
hear how can we rethink this how what do
we need to rethink thinking about doing
I don't think they really want to hear
that the plastic bag has to go but
mm-hmm what actually concerns me about
your answer is that you're not getting
invited by environmental groups well I
think if any yeah some some but not not
a ton you know and I I don't know what
that is and I suspect some of it is that
I'm not wholeheartedly I'm not only
saying all PLAs
is bad I mean I'm saying you know
there's good plastic it has to be used
better ha ha that okay that's a little
worrying to me that the industry guys
are more open to this mixed message of
yours then my fellow environmentalists
maybe or maybe you know they just figure
out reaching to the choir I don't know
was there an issue of their you are
talking to the specialists in the
plastics industry you you know got their
graduate degrees and whatever and are
you know really know the stuff backward
before and you come in and you sort of
have to say hi I'm not an engineer I'm a
journalist what happens then it you've
got a fair amount of technical stuff and
you're booking in your presentation
which i think is wonderful because
that's the level of detail that a lot of
these issues have to be hashed out at
but our guys in the industry you know
with that or what happens if they're
okay with that guys in the industry know
their little thing plastics is this huge
sprawling industry and what is
interesting to me is people know their
own little section of it so the guys who
you know make plastic film know all
about plastic film and don't know
anything about medical devices you know
or the issues related to medical devices
that you know the guys who make bottles
know about bottles but they don't know
anything about car parts there aren't a
lot of people who are sort of overall
experts there's no longer any like
there's there's global conferences where
everybody having to do with plastic
espagueti have never been to one there
is that there is a triennial national
plastics conference that takes place
every year the case show the every three
years the case show but I actually never
made it to them here comes more
questions thank you aha
Rachael whiting harrass our 3d printers
the rebirth of Yardley cousin plastic
utopia how could we make it better for
this plastic revolution so there's you
know zillions and makers out there and
are delighted to have this thing that
makes things and it makes them out of a
useable plastic you know I don't know
anything about 3d printers I was
supposed to go to nature noise bridge
tomorrow night to see the
3d printer makers ferry guys but I think
Alexander was saying to me that they're
starting to use biopolymers that some of
the polymers that are using these 3d
printers actually are not biodegradable
or even particularly recyclable things
but there is that same kind of
excitement I mean designers were
thrilled in the 50s over plastics
because suddenly they had these
materials they could you know I write
about the development of plastic chairs
I mean chairs didn't have to be these
Square boxy rectilinear things you could
get these wild curvy you know insane
chairs because plastics made it possible
and in fact Charles Eames who was you
know utterly excited about plastic also
thought it was almost a dangerous
material he said he compared it to the
way the Aztecs thought about alcohol
that it was something that should only
be reserved for the mature audience nod
artists because you know who knew what
they would do with it there's a question
what plastics do you think we will or
should be manufacturing in 100 years
time long now kind of question so it's
been about a hundred years that we've
had plastics so far and and one of the
things pretty interesting is you you
know he had this huge proliferation of
kinds of plastic and then basically
proliferation of uses of plastic and now
proliferation of volume of plastic which
is going up and up and these interesting
nuances that the bio plastic is not all
that bio and the degradable plastic is
not a lot degradable and the recyclable
plastic is a mixed bag that's by the way
I think one of the messages I get from
your researchers that there's not simple
solutions there are solutions I don't
know here's the trend going it what's
the future of this I can tell you where
I hope the trend is going I don't know
that it's really going there but again I
mean a hundred years from now you're not
gonna see fossil fuel-based plastics for
the most part that's just not
sustainable it's not credible every
major company is looking at bio-based
plastics and in looking at ways to make
either wholly new plastics
the same plastic out of renewable
sources my hope is that what will be the
feedstocks for that are going to be
waste that it's not gonna be corn grown
to make Barbies that's that's sort of
insane or to make you know picnic forks
I think green chemistry and sort of the
incorporation of green chemistry
principles and green chemistry
departments in major manufacturing
companies means that hopefully what you
will see is plastics that you know take
into account these sort of the full
lifecycle cradle to grave cradle to
cradle lifecycle I don't know though I
think it's probably likely what you'll
see is some of the conventional plastics
maybe some of the plastics we still have
but just you know made from a plant
source so it'll be polyethylene but
it'll come from sugarcane or you know if
we're lucky it'll come from I don't know
AG waste is the you know I've sort of
referred to the guys that the companies
you went to are they guys in how old are
they they're young you know we're back
to the movie are there young engineers
getting into doing cool new things for
the plastic yeah there are and I you
know I mean there's still polymer
engineering departments around I don't
know if it's interesting I don't know
how much polymer engineers think about
this stuff though there was a guy who's
head of the polymer engineering
department at UMass Lowell who I had
talked to several times and he's very
interested in recycling and sort of
end-of-life issues and I sent him a copy
of my book before I sent him a copy of
the manuscript sort of hoping that he
would vet it and I got an email back
saying well you know I haven't read it
yet but I don't think that title is very
accurate he was very hostile to
criticism you know there there are guys
and and yeah there are young guys in the
in the field but you know probably I
don't I don't know I don't know if I
should I don't know how to compare it
you mentioned green chemistry and this
seems to be a workaround of the chemical
by chemical hopelessness of testing
80,000 chemical
etc etc you see a little more about
green chemistry and how I especially
worked in plastic domain well I mean
green chemistry starts from the
principle that you're not going to
create molecules that are going to be
harmful to human health or the
environment so one of the things I think
is really exciting and the movement of
green chemistry is starting to get the
people who make molecules thinking about
toxicology thinking about environmental
consequences sort of thinking long-term
and that's happening in places you know
Berkeley's got the Center for green
chemistry and they are actually working
with you know the biology department and
the engineering department and policy
department so that the people who are
being trained to create molecules are
being trained to think beyond you know
just oh I've got this cool new thing you
know I've got this cool new molecule
what can I do with it
which just simply wasn't in the thinking
of the last generation of industrial
chemists is there a book as good as
yours about green chemistry if not will
you write it well you know Elisabeth
Grossman has this book chasing molecules
which i think is pretty good she and
she's been doing a lot of writing about
green chemistry and I think I think
she's smart and good chasing molecule
chasing molecules outstanding nice title
fellow named Dale asks are you available
to speak to our company's a sewer the
answer is yes
what are the chances ask Dale hover of
us developing a usefully tunable I
imagine plastic eating bacteria I mean
my first thought is okay that's it for a
simple yeah well you know they're these
guys from Yale who came who found this
fungus in the Amazon that it turns out
that they claim eats polyurethane you
know I don't know that's why we've got
to keep the trafficking force there's
things out there I mean here I sort of
come up with like why would we want that
again this is these are valuable
materials do we really want them to go
away or do we want to keep these
molecules in circulation as long as
possible in one form or another I mean I
guess you know you could compose
plastics are there bacteria that you
want to put in the composting pile that
would eat plastic I don't know I don't
know what the unintended consequences of
that would be it seems to me we want to
make this stuff go away and it seems to
me the way to think about it more is you
know how do we make use of this stuff in
a way that you know doesn't create
problems how do we keep these molecules
in circulation how do we reduce the
amount that we need to make so that we
don't have to you know one of the
criticisms of recycling is that so much
plastic gets down cycled that it doesn't
really dent the need to creep keep
creating virgin plastic and I think
that's the you know that's the issue
more that we need to sort of address and
think about let me try a free radical
how much of these molecules is carbon I
don't know the answer but you know
carbon is the common most common
backbone because looking at the
greenhouse gas issue the the main deal
that everybody is trying to figure out
is how the hell do we capture and
sequester carbon and the best way to
leave the coal in the damn ground after
that it's out there it's in the
atmosphere there's air capture these
various kinds of things one of the keys
of plastic is that it is fossil fuels
you say there's going to be a boom with
the with the fracking and the shale gas
dropping the price of everything that's
you know changing the whole ecology of
renewable resources and all the rest of
it so that gas the carbon that gas which
is less than an oil that's still fair
amount of carbon is then going into the
plastic which you say has this quality
of lasting a very very very long time I
think you see where I'm going this looks
like a hell of a way to sequester carbon
I you know I get yeah possibly
oh then we move on - okay everybody use
lots of plastic and don't throw it in
the ocean where it's not in my sea
turtles but get it into the landfill and
then I want to know is there a way where
it can be totally anaerobic down there
so it's not turning whatever it makes so
it doesn't make methane can you do that
can you seal up fresh kills or whatever
it is so it's not making methane or do
you tap it so perfectly that all the
methane that does get made comes out in
a way that you can reuse it turn it back
in the plastic whatever the hell it is
is there any reason to believe that
plastic is a good way to sequester
carbon I don't really expect it yeah I
don't I don't I don't know does anybody
have an answer to that well if I am is
the whole thing as could be one of these
things I mean if I am is a funny issue
coming around to that about 1% 3% of
landfill is is residential and so you
know all the careful collecting that we
do with recycling all that kind of stuff
3% of what actually goes into the
landfill a lot of its building materials
and industrial less than that and so on
so the thing I always worry about
frankly with environmental virtuous
behavior of recycling and whatnot is how
much of it is making us think we're
doing something when we're not even
touching the level of the issues I mean
the cat you know I don't know I mean I
think that's an interesting question the
calculations that I've seen on comparing
recycling to you know the continuing
making Virgin resin which you know if
you just landfilled
the stuff and said okay we don't need to
recycle because this we're gonna
sequester all the old plastic and
landfill the calculations have seen
comparing this really closed coal mine
Osceola mine the comparisons I've seen
is that you know the carbon footprint of
recycling is significantly lower than
making virgin resin so how much Lord
Knight you know I don't know offhand
significantly lower is significantly
lower and and so you know we can throw
all the use plastic and landfill a
sequester right there but then if
continue to consume plastic at the same
rate you're back at the same position
where you gotta create new stuff one of
the things you pointed out about
bakelite early on is oh it's really
solid and lasts a long time I mean those
little bakelite telephones if you've got
one in the closet you can keep it until
it's valuable because it's not as you
point out there's this bridge it is
perfectly well built so you know maybe
part of the direction to go is is more
and more things made of plastic that
earns its forever value that you know
you are making really durable stuff with
this really durable material well you
know one of the things that I think is
interesting about the plastics issue is
that it really speaks to more than just
a material issue I mean yeah that would
be great
the problem is that we live in a culture
that encourages constant consumption and
acquisition so it'd be great if you made
a phone that lasts forever but you know
we change out our cell phones what every
18 months you know we don't live in a
culture that encourages endurance and
and so one of the things that I think is
sort of there's not a lot of volume here
no no I've been but but you get what I'm
saying oh yeah cycling up the cars is
probably a bigger deal you know I mean I
think when you start to sort of think
about plastic one of the objects that I
look at in the book is the credit card I
use that as the object the book uses
different objects to examine different
issues and I used it as the object these
are all made of PVC by the way I forget
is that good or bad
no PVC I think is not a good plastic do
not eat your credit do not burn your
credit card more to the point
interesting people burn draft cards and
browse all kinds of things nobody burns
credit but you know I used the credit
card because people are trying to make
credit cards out of biodegradable
plastics which is a questionable
Enterprise for Star
but also Menino what people find when
they start trying to trim their use of
plastics is their consumption goes down
because you can't consume as much if you
say I'm not going to buy as much plastic
there's a woman in the East Bay Beth
Terry who's been a anti plastic blogger
for for about five years now she has
this blog plastic free life which is a
great source of information if you want
to reduce plastic free life blog if and
she has a book coming out in June I'll
plug her book if you if you want to
reduce your plastic footprint she's
actually got great hints on how to make
shampoo out of baking soda but you know
she talked about how once she decided to
stop acquiring new plastic stuff
she stopped consuming as much and found
other ways to get the things that she
needed you know when she needed a
screwdriver or a hammer she could go to
the tool lending library when she she
doesn't own a car you know some of her
stuff is extreme but I think I think
critiquing plastic does sort of take you
into a broader critique of the whole way
that we live and grappling with plastic
and the problems that plastic creates
does in some way bring you back to
having to grapple with how we live
that's interesting I'd like the
plasticine as a we've had the
homogeneous scene and the Anthropocene
in the plasticine clearly is something
that geologists of the future will can
well yeah where the plasticine layer I
wonder if it'll be one of those things
where you know ever after it's like once
you see vertebrates and they're its
vertebrates all the way up
once you see plastic is it plastic all
the way up or is that a just a layer you
know everybody knows well that was back
in the X centuries but it was only two
centuries long and then now they use the
question I'm guessing based on the
issues that you've spelled out here that
it will be a shallow layer and if it
where it's not that way you'll be partly
responsible
thank you for doing
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]